so I'm gonna be talking about logging
obviously so but first a couple of
apologies
the first apology is to the guy with the
camera I'm gonna be moving around a lot
and the second apology is to you guys
because I was expecting to be I was
expecting to be doing this talk
preparing the talk over the last bank
holiday weekend you know finishing it up
I ended up going sailing instead on the
Norfolk Broads so I spent the whole time
in a boat in the ring which you'll hear
about in a second so I'm gonna switch
the first slide so the camera can sync
up and this is kind of an interactive
first session put your hands up if you
talk about logging in your code style
guides at work okay inverse put your
hand up if you do it sorry if you don't
if you don't okay fine
yeah so people don't tend to talk about
logging very much which is weird
considering it's like one of the oldest
things that we do in software back when
we log two pieces of paper before us
born probably so we don't talk about
logging in our style guides has anybody
ever been taught
logging best practices okay put your
hand up if you have not been taught
logging best practices no put your hand
up if you've ever thought about logging
best practices okay cool
this is awesome few people has anybody
ever tested their logs put your hand up
tested your logs nice tested JavaScript
logs okay so my name's Joseph roof I am
at Jay Reeve zero on twitter at Joe on
the slack group for this for this kind
of community if you want my details you
can go to Joe contact me during and the
slides should you want to find them at
that link take a picture now if you want
this title also be at the end so log
books this is kind of coming into the
sailing thing log books are really
really cool because we've been doing
this for
ages right people on boats have been
sitting down every hour when they're out
at sea they say this is our heading when
I'm writing this look this is what the
wind is like yeah standard stuff about
boats and that kind of gets locked in a
box which hopefully should the ship sink
somebody else can come along and find it
the floating box is kind of somewhere on
the sea they know what the ship is they
know where they were when it all went
wrong they know what the conditions were
and potentially you know they can
actually diagnose the exact reason this
ship sunk in the middle of the night
somewhere yeah and they also know what's
on it
so is it worth going and looking for and
finding all the hidden treasure on at
the bottom of the sea but also is it
worth sending out a rescue party was it
just one person and you know this dog
book is being found 20 years later so
when I went sailing the guys at the boat
yard where I rented the boat they know
me I've been there for a while they said
since you've had last had this boat
these are the things we've changed the
bilge washers so the bilge is the the
bit of water kind of underneath the
floor so there's a little kind of it's
called the bilge a little bit of air
that water can go into and if that gets
too full water starts coming up through
the floor and you start to sink
basically but generally boats are always
slowly sinking and we have little pumps
that take the water out of the boat they
also change the countertops lovely if
we've got these nice granite looking
countertops now which is brilliant
they changed the water heater which is
cool because now we get hot water and
they changed the engine they also
changed a bunch of batteries and stuff
so they said to me seeing as we know you
and seeing as all this stuff in you when
you're the first car of the year which
at the time I thought was great now I
know it's not seeing as you're the first
part of the year the first one to use
all of this cool new stuff could you
keep a log of the bilge pump how long do
you hold a bilge pump for so the whole
holiday went really really well
I got back on Monday evening except the
countertop fell off and broke four
bottles of beer the beer from the
bottles then went into the Pilcher
the water heater used up all of our
water when it shouldn't have and put all
the excess water into the bilge the
engine died which was fun in the middle
of nowhere and then it rained on stop
and does anyone know where the rain goes
in a boat say it out loud
into the bilge exactly into the bilge so
this was me in the rain with a cup of
coffee it's kind of ok so now let's talk
about JavaScript logging because that's
why we're all here right well that's why
I'm here at least JavaScript logging is
cool because it's kind of not done very
much but there's loads of kind of prior
art so us JavaScript developers and lots
of developers have a really really nasty
habit we tend to reinvent the wheel over
and over again has anyone heard of web
workers
alright that's threading accidentally
reinvented badly or worklets which is
reinventing the the actor model but
without having the name so you can't
Google what it is but kind of the time
when I had the red pill you know I mean
matrix tile I started to actually think
about logging when I was talking to a
friend of mine Julian who's the back on
his phone so he's doing a lot of work in
analytics and logging software a lot of
Android stuff and non JavaScript stuff
but I went over and I had a chat with
him and we talked about logging for 3-4
hours and this is the first one would
actually talk to someone about logging
because surely like console dot log it
worked
you know console dot log debug hello so
I talked to him about about this and it
wasn't boring which was the first thing
that surprised me talking about logging
wasn't boring and then I went to work
the next morning and saw this log nice
this statement this bit of code and I
was like what get blame launch missiles
kill them who on earth did this which
obviously if any of you have ever done a
get blade on a piece of code that looks
rubbish don't because always you that
wrote it
so I was looking at this code and I was
thinking this is bad
this console dot log statement is bad
and I have no idea why it's bad right
just no idea I just I know because I've
had this conversation but I don't know
why it's bad right so I started looking
for other things constant that log error
error message right why is that bad come
to it consult of error faz on that is
has anyone here ever work with the
Hungarian yeah a Hungarian programmer
yeah put that into Google Translate the
polite translation is oh [ __ ]
and then console dot log finished at
date dot now does anyone know what date
are now outputs a bunch of numbers right
not human readable so I was like these
are all bad all of these hundreds of log
statements in this code base that I'm
responsible for are bad you know I can't
look at the logs and know what's going
on know if the systems even okay let
alone if the users are okay and these
are systems running you know the a
couple of layers down people are trading
half a million pounds on a day or are
deciding whether not to run trains like
these are dangerous systems if things go
wrong luckily this isn't directly it but
this is kind of a couple of layers away
so I kind of thought about it for awhile
and I thought there are four dimensions
for things that you can kind of focus on
you can think about specifically that
make a log good or bad so you've got
context what's going on in the app
what's the data what's the time what's
yeah we'll come back what's the purpose
is it for debugging and I'm going to I
think I'm going to delete it before I
commit it is it for auditing you know we
did have this many users log in and the
product owner knows it and they went to
these sites and they did this and this
and this is it important is someone
about to die is someone about to lose
half a million pounds or was there a
garbage collection event and the format
is it human readable is it Greta bull
you know grep unix crap
yeah can I just grab my logs and see
every time this dog user logged in or
can I grab my logs and see every time
there was an error every time something
went wrong the purpose so we might be
doing analytics which is a kind of
logging I promise you you can ask me
about it later the purpose is it for
debugging or is it for analytics
improving the user experience did
someone die did so much as log in was
there a garbage collection event you
know is it scannable
is it possible which is really really
important if you're using something like
log stash single head of log stash it's
at all
you know elastic search guys for dealing
with logs
so that's contact purpose importance and
format they're all things that are
important when we're writing logs so
none of this stuff is new you can see
examples of all this stuff in log4j
which is a Java logging library which is
kind of industry standard for Java stuff
the syslog standard which is kind of has
bits of bits of stuff just look it up on
online countly which there are some
stickers around somewhere they I had a
chat with the CEO and he sent me some
stickers which they open source rocks
which is cool so they're over there
somewhere and that's just a tool for you
know logging events logging errors
locking different things to a remote
location from the client or from other
languages log stash and good old console
dot you know we've got console dot log
error warn info different kind of levels
importances and then we've got things
like timing and profiler loads of really
cool stuff just open dev tools like
console dot and look at the intellisense
really cool stuff so this is an example
of a bad format of logs has anybody seen
this in their log files where's your
hands have you seen something like this
in your log files yeah someone should
log down some array and you just got
object object object object takes up
hundreds of lines of logs and yeah you
know you kind of lose the context so
this is this breaks any context you've
got a good format is showing the user
that logged in wrapping things in square
brackets makes things really possible
it's surprising I mean I'm going to say
read regular
Russians right but if you need to do
something quickly regular expressions
are really handy or graphing for things
using very large equations
logging errors instead of doing consult
log
bla error message just log the actual
error not appended to a string and
they'll actually display the whole stack
trace which is lovely and this is this
is an example of showing context this is
IP addresses so we're showing context of
where this stuff happened from which is
important when we come to this kind of
thing right use logged in user logged in
user logged in error got data pretty
rubbish because we don't know what's
going on this means a lot different
right so we've got the same user logged
in five times within one second
either we've got a bug or we've got a
bot right both of these things are
important and if you've got your IP
address you can start looking at the IP
address is it a real user is it some
kind of bots Graper we've had that a lot
stealing lots of valuable data they pay
for one user and there they've got their
BOTS going off and downloading huge
amounts of data so it all depends on the
goal the logs that you actually use the
logging statements the logging context
the data I can't just come up here and
say log the IP addresses all of the
users or whatever you know I can't say
log this log that because it depends so
much on your individual context on your
application on your users and on what
you're expected to provide for your
customers so it depends on the goal has
anyone read the goal by Eli gold round
know what okay first thing you do when
you get home go on Amazon all of the
goal it's about Kanban management or
something but it's really really good at
helping you understand where in an
organization developers you know
developers fit and how they can help
with why organization so there's this
thing I made up this morning called the
logging type table and basically this is
talking about the different types of
logging the different reasons you might
use a log statement so we've got some
things it's a bit small different
different types of logging so there's
there's something called tracings anyone
heard the term tracing before yeah
okay so tracing is often used for
debugging it's kind of logging function
in vacations or individual variables and
just for really when when there's some
bug that you're looking at so the
question it answers is what happened you
know how do we get here
what happened what did the user do to
get to this point or what data came in
to get to this point and we usually log
the state changes and function in
vacations and it's targeted at
developers so there's anyone heard of
event logging fairly common term event
logging it's analytics understanding
what's going on inside the app is that a
user doing specific things or is it the
application doing specific things so
what's happening actions and exceptions
and it's useful for administrators
product owners and kind of us as
developers we know which bits of code to
specifically improve progress logging
which is something that probably we
don't think much about this can actually
feedback to users of applications has
anyone ever used DD the units tall DD
raise your hands
no one's your DD what has anyone ever
moved an image file not a dot IMG onto
an SD card for like a rosary pie or
something Wow okay so DD is an example
of bad logging because you press DD and
it starts copying this three gigabyte
file onto an SD card and it just so the
command did it yeah the UNIX utility
yeah so DD you type DD this big file
onto this SD card which I haven't used
in three years maybe it'll work and it
just sits there staring at you blank
right no logging no explanation of
what's going on it just kind of sits
there and then come back in half an hour
and hopefully it's worked ok so that's
that's kind of induces a lot of anxiety
in its users so the question Oh
so progress logging is all about
answering the question are you ok are
you still working have you
crashed is there anything I can do to
help basically so we kind of log
percentage of progress what errors have
happened what's going on targeted it
users because this can bubble up to some
application if I click a button in on
some website and it starts churning away
chugging away and doesn't load in five
seconds I'm gonna hit refresh right but
if some pop-up comes up and says this is
going to take a while
we're loading the page for you we're
aggregating the data then you're more
likely to kind of wait for it right so
then there's audit which is kind of
something that we really really don't
think think about much which is kind of
very verifying that the behavior of the
application is correct yeah
did when my bank sent money do they log
saying we transferred this much money
from this account to this account and
this accounts you know amount of money
decreased by the same amount and this
account increased all right this is kind
of double entry bookkeeping that's what
counts do is they just look at the data
from different angles and they just make
sure everything lines up and this is
something that your compliance
departments might need the government
might want my GD P R type stuff and the
rest of the business might want because
they want to know how many users are
working you know using the tool is the
number of subscribers going down every
month which is obviously a bad thing
yeah so that's the the logging type
table so purple slides again we're
nearly at the end don't worry I'm just
going to wrap up the sailing stuff so oh
no I'm not I'm gonna do this instead
so the log and golden rules the three
things to consider when you're writing
logs and then I'm gonna wrap up the same
stuff
remember the reader so this is who's
reading the data is it going to be
passed are they going to be unable to
understand what's going on do they know
the context no personal data no
passwords I've seen that a lot no
passwords no usernames no email
addresses depends on the context
obviously and then answer the question
think about what question are you trying
to answer with these locks are you
trying to answer how do we get here are
you trying to answer are you functioning
correctly are you trying to answer
answer this random question that the
marketing guy said hey I'd really love
to know how many users log in
every three seconds or every three days
right if there's some specific thing
that's that's kind of the question and
you need to make sure that that's
understandable in the logs itself okay
sailing now we're on sailing so this was
my log that I kept in a book with paper
and pen
I mean hardcore stuff right so there are
a few things that we can we can kind of
keep take note of that we can actually
learn so this is a vent logging this is
me saying I did this and it happened for
this long so this is when I pick the
boat up yeah you can see that though
well the day I pick the boat up and
first time I ran the test and it ran for
kind of three seconds and then you can
see something went wrong because
suddenly my bilge pump the thing that's
supposed to stop me from sinking takes
12 seconds to do its job and then some
engineer came in the middle of the day
you'll see by the arrest of the log said
it's kind of a weird time in the middle
of the day he came and he fixed
something and then ran it for ten
seconds so this is an abnormal log
alright so something different happened
and then you can see something went
wrong it's not immediately obvious but
if you're kind of displaying this in a
graph it's quite helpful that I actually
missed the morning here I missed the
morning on the second of the fourth and
that's because our we have more issues
with our wort eater and suddenly
worrying about actually being able to
drink water was more important than than
measuring how long our bills compliment
ran for so that's something else went
wrong and then that's when I ran that
just before I dropped the boat off so
another interesting thing is after the
the tests are after the guy fixed it
these tests are all very similar even
though the amount of rain changes right
so the actual test runs change so don't
change much sorry which means there's
probably a lot of overhead in the pump
from spinning up right but there's a lot
of overhead and you can tell because the
values are similar not because they're
different
so similarities in logs is still really
really handy okay that's it you can
drink more beer eat more pizza cool
you
[Applause]